about two years after my diagnosis I
went to Germany and I did a bunch of
stem cell um replacement uh no it was my
own it it was they harvested my own stem
cells so I had so what they did their
belief at this Clinic I went to was you
have an autoimmune disease so therefore
your immune system isn't functioning
correctly so let's get your immune
system functioning correctly they did
all these crazy detoxes I did like
cation therapy and ozone therapy and had
all these like IVs and everything was in
Germany in Germany for like a 10day
period And in that 10 days that
harvesting uh they harvested my stem
cells from my blood so you the moment
you get there they hook you up and they
take out like a vast amount of blood um
and and it made sense to me I was like
oh wait a second I have an autoimmune
disease that affects my neurological
system why am I only treating the
symptom of this disease why am I not
treating the root of this disease and so
that's kind of the the thought process
at this Clinic I went to so um I did did
the whole treatment there um I felt
great I lit I I did not have I didn't
have a cold or a flu or anything for
like three years it was amazing did you
think you were Cur cured I don't I don't
think because I don't think it works
that way I think it I it's my belief
that like Ms is on like a cellular level
like I don't think it's something that
they can just cure but what I think they
did was they were able
to kind
of re rebuild my immune system in such a
way that my body has a natural ability
to kind of keep it at Bay now if you go
to a if I would have talked to a
neurologist or if I would have talked to
anyone who's a professional in the MS
field they're going to go it doesn't
work that way and were they not amazed
at how you were my my neurologist is
very amazed at my progress he's very
much like huh has America adopted any of
this
in certain ways and in and and not in
others some you know we're getting in
America they're getting a little closer
to Stem Cell like being more accepting
of it and understanding of it and uh and
it's really weird as to why I think
there's a big misconception here as to
why stem cells aren't as popular as they
are and most people think it's because
oh you're you're using like embryotic
tissue or fetal tissue and and things
like that and in and in certain cases
that is what is required but it it's
actually to do with the time and
duration tissue and cells are out of the
body in in America you can't put you
can't have any human tissue out of a
human body for more than 24 hours and
they need numerous multiple days to grow
the stem cells so that's why like organ
donors right they have 24 hours to get
that organ in the new in the patient
because there's a as it was explained to
me and I could be totally wrong but as
it was explained to me they are unsure
what happens to human cells that are out
of the Body for more than 24 hours they
don't know what like they could corrupt
they could go gang grous I don't know
they sometimes it's just a stain on a
comforter
right why wouldn't they just I don't I
don't really know that much about Ms but
like why would they just do kind of like
a transplant and take stem cells from
someone else that has healthy a healthy
immune system and then so I because I I
as as far as I know your own stem cells
are always going to work the best
because they come from you that's but
that's not always the case because you
can get uh like embryotic stem cells and
stem cells from umbilical cords and
stuff and and that as they explained to
me in Germany and that is the caveat is
like this is I'm this is all as it as it
was explained to me um and you don't
speak a word of German I don't speak a
word of German no but I we'll get we'll
get into some depressing stuff too about
that clinic which is kind of interesting
after this story but the um
the like if you're if you're older you
have less stem cells so people who are
kind of 60 70 80 they need the embryotic
stem cells because you want to get as
many cells as possible so just a a
little uh stuff for a second I always
ask people to sub subscribe or go to Hoy
mandel.com but at my age if you could
send me stem cells I sa my kid stem
cells so you can have them if you want
to thank you and but also for people who
are subscribing all right apparently I
need them send it too yeah uh but here's
the depressing part about that they go
I'm Inman you're going to tell us
something really depressing do we want
depressing music it's not overly depress
it's just kind of like but say it's
really depressing and it's amazing and
then we'll use that as a bridge over
this ad a commercial okay and now we're
back and now we're back for the
depressing story thanks let's see how
many people hung in for depression go
ahead so the clinic that I went to
they're like oh we actually we don't
they don't harvest the cells on site
they send it off to a lab and they're
like it's actually the oldest lab in
Germany oh no that does this yeah when
you talk about the oldest lab in Germany
to Jews are and I'm like well how old is
this lab thinking maybe the 70s ' 80s
whatever they're like
1947 basically it was a bunch of Nazi
doctors that did all these
twisted experiments during the
war they were like oh okay well now we
know how to do this stem cell stuff so
war ends in 45 and they're like well
let's just open up a
clinic